[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man 3
marvel video and an update on all the
canceled and delayed Marvel movies that
have changed in the last couple of weeks
we started with a couple movies that
have been canceled and delayed now
there's a bunch more if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos we're doing an
Amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave all
your theories about sinister 6 in
spider-man 3 on the video so just going
down the list starting with number 5 Tom
Hollands spider-man 3 was originally
going to be filming in the middle of
July this year it was on the same basic
schedule as spider-man far from home so
if you remember when I was posting
videos about that originally it would
have been about the same this year the
working title is serenity now it's a big
Seinfeld a stray I've already done a
video about that so I'll post a link at
the end of the video even though
everyone's posting the spider-man worked
from home memes I still love the title
spider-man home run if we're keeping
home in the title of spider-man 3 Marvel
had just announced the creatives that it
had hired to film the movie in Tom
Holland was speaking about the story of
the movie recently I'll talk about that
in a second too but then the
cinematographers that they just hired
Simas McGarvey revealed that spider-man
3 too had just become a casualty of the
virus delays that are affecting pretty
much every movie and TV series that are
trying to film right now through the
summer fun fact to bringing this back
around to the classic MCU Marvel
infinity saga movies he's worked on a
bunch of other MCU movies CMAs mcgarvey
was the DP on Joss Whedon's first
Avengers movie and he filmed that first
Thor post-credit scene which was the
special tesseract scene in Nick Fury's
base when Erik Selvig goes to study it
before Loki returns looking none the
worse for wear
well I guess that's why it's been so
long since I've watched that scene but
that was basically meant to be the first
big Avengers teaser so it's always cool
to see notable people show up all over
different MCU movies in front of in
behind the camera
speaking of which number four Sam Raimi
we can't forget that even though
spider-man 3 might be the next big
delayed Marvel movie it's also going to
be filming at the same time the director
of the other spider-man 3 movie is
filming Doctor Strange 2 multiverse of
badness I haven't talked about Doctor
Strange too since they released the
Wanda vision trailer mostly because so
much of Wanda vision is going to set up
Doctor Strange 2 in Marvel's already
told us a lot about what they're doing
with her character and why she's teaming
up with Doctor Strange
even though I do love to see all the
theories that she's secretly the villain
of Doctor Strange 2 not one of the
heroes without demonizing her character
or anything like that she's dealing with
the grief of losing vision and obviously
experiencing this alternate life with
him jumping across space-time in
alternate realities in her chaos magic
is going to start blossoming as Doctor
Strange so Apple II told Iron Man I
protect your reality douchebag he
protects our reality from threats from
other dimensions I'm going to allow them
so one division and Scarlet Witch
probably accidentally create that threat
from another dimension but that doesn't
necessarily make her the villain of
Doctor Strange - number three all the
new canceled and delayed Marvel movies
so since they cancelled the Black Widow
released a here's everything that's
changed with the other big Marvel movies
and everything has changed quite a bit
Marvel hasn't said when Black Widow or
New Mutants are gonna be released I know
a lot of people are hoping for video
on-demand New Mutants is probably the
only movie that they would consider
dropping video-on-demand but they're
done they're good to go
shanky and The Legend of the ten rings
also just got delayed originally it was
supposed to come out in the middle of
February next year they've been away
from filming for so long that there's no
way they're gonna make that release date
so shang-chi is probably gonna come out
in March next year Doctor Strange to the
multiverse of madness was the next big
Marvel movie that took a hit mr.
spider-man Sam Raimi himself was
supposed to start filming that movie in
May and if the July movies that are
filming then have already been delayed
you can bet that the ones that were
filming in May are gonna be delayed to
originally Doctor Strange 2 was supposed
to come out at the beginning of May 2021
now that's probably gonna be the end of
May or early June which isn't that big
of a deal just a couple weeks delay they
also just had to cut the Loki series
short they were in the middle of filming
that was supposed to come out around
March next year in air for six weeks
right before Doctor Strange 2 started
now Loki is probably gonna come out
sometime in April Marvel still claims
that Falcon and Winter Soldier in one
division were mostly done filming their
episodes and they're still on track to
release those when they originally
planned to Falcon and Winter Soldier was
supposed to start in August Wanda vision
is still supposed to start in December
both of those series are six episodes
Thor for love and thunder in the Hawkeye
series weren't supposed to start filming
til the end of this year so they're
probably safe mostly even though Jeremy
Renner kinda made it seem like Hawkeye
had been delayed moon night and she Hook
weren't supposed to start filming till
after Hawkeye so they're also probably
mostly safe ant-man 3 wasn't gonna start
filming till January next year we
learned that from Michael Douglas thank
you very much for leaking that it's
probably totally safe and then guardians
of the galaxy 3 which is the other big
confirmed movie wasn't gonna start
filming until after Suicide Squad 2
comes out in theaters which means that
they wouldn't start filming till the end
of next year so they're totally safe and
bringing up the rear Deadpool himself
Deadpool 3 is in development which just
means that the writers and Ryan Reynolds
are trying to figure out what the
story's going to be they can totally do
that from their homes in their pajamas
so even though we only have rumors that
is going to be released during 2022 it
will not be delayed I'm really relieved
busy doing some stuff and
[Music]
you've done given too much attention
that's why I can't be there right now
the rumor is Deadpool 3 will be October
2022 but if there's any more information
about that I'll totally do a new
Deadpool video there was a secret
spider-man spin-off movie the Sony put
on the schedule they're just calling it
their untitled spider-man spin-off movie
we don't know what it's going to be but
that's also been delayed too but number
two there are rumors right now that
Craven really is the main villain of
spider-man 3 I've done a couple
spider-man 3 videos talking about the
director in how much time he's spent
talking about the Kraven character
inside a spider-man movie in how much
the Kraven character has history within
the MCU originally he was going to be
the villain of the first Black Panther
movie but there's been a rumor about the
plot recently that they will do a
version of MCU Cravens last hunt take it
with a grain of salt but it does sound
like they're trying to spend more time
in spider-man 3 slowly setting up more
sinister six stuff in as part of that
there will be a big sinister six figure
pulling the strings orchestrating all
these events against spider-man I have
taken the liberty of arrange some bars
for your lab starting bid my buyers
don't take no for an answer
so we a the in business together number
one also as part of these rumors people
think that it's supposed to be the MCU
version of Norman Osborn
there have been a lot of Easter eggs in
the MCU movies so far that could be
Norman Osborn Easter eggs like the
mysterious quote-unquote benefactor that
sunny birch works for with billions of
dollars to spend like its pocket change
for a while it did seem like Marvel was
trying to set up a big foil for Tony
Stark an evil version of Tony Stark and
then they spent all of spider-man far
from home talking about the legacy of
Iron Man who would take up the legacy
Mysterio was trying to usurp that from
spider-man
most of us as fans assumed that
spider-man would be the one to assume
the mantle of Tony Stark even though
he'd never be Iron Man he'd always be
spider-man is that you need out of that
single figure to rally around a big
Avengers level figure but if you
remember the Dark Reign store
I'm from the comics that sort of the
dark twists on that concept Norman
Osborn usurping what you would consider
Tony Stark's place in the MCU take it
with a grain of salt we don't know if
the rumors are true but it would be cool
to see a new MCU version of Norman
Osborn at some point even though if
they're doing this as part of their
sinister six plans Norman Osborn's Green
Goblin wasn't a founding member of the
sinister six in the comics dr. octopus
was originally the first person to put
the team together so hopefully we'll see
MCU dr. octopus at some point recently I
also did a video about how Sony claims
that they're planning on signing a new
sharing deal for spider-man to keep him
in the MCU after their current deal is
done
that'll cover spider-man 4 which won't
come out till July 2023 so it's very
possible that spider-man 4 could be that
sinister six movie so they've been a
bunch of movies that have been delayed
but it's not all bad news there's still
a lot of cool stuff going on and there
will still be some movies that will come
later this year Marvel's eternals is
still on the schedule for November they
haven't changed that yet we still have
all the Disney Plus stuff the
mandalorian season 2 1 division Falcon
and Winter Soldier and I will do a new
video when they finally reveal what
they're going to do with the black widow
movie I think we all kind of expect them
to release New Mutants video on demand
just because no one was expecting that
movie to make a ton of money anyway
but everyone post all your theories in
the comments below do you want them to
do a new MCU version of Norman Osborn at
some point congratulations impulse here
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your details everyone click here for
that brand new venom 2 video and click
here for my other brand new spider-man 3
Marvel video thank you so much for
watching everyone stays safe see you
guys tonight